Instructor: Remember
we talked about the for-of loop,
and how it pretty much works
with absolutely everything
except for objects? Well, it
actually works on looping
through generators as well.
Let's take a quick look at an
example right here, where I'll
create a generator called lyrics.
This lyrics function is just
going to yield a line of, "My
Achy Breaky Heart," every single
time that we go through to it.
I'm going to just type "yield"
in front of each one. To go
through this, we could call
create a new generator. Let's do
that. We see we have achy.
next.next.next.next.next. What
if we don't want to manually
call that, and we don't want to
write some sort of recursive
function? Well, you can use the
for-of loop...and just console.
log the line. Notice how we're
not going to call next anywhere
in here. It just console.logs it
all for us. That's really
useful if you've got a generator
that has either some hard-coded
stuff that you need to loop
through, or even better yet, you
have a dynamic function that
would generate some code for you,
or some lines, or some numbers,
or some objects. Whatever
type of content it is, you can
just use the for-of loop to loop
right through it, just like it
does on arrays, and sets, and
maps, and everything else we
talked about with the for-of
loop.